eu não quero a minha vida eu pensei ser
professor para Estava a fazer um estágio
de engenharia adorava projetar
equipamentos fazer engenhocas achei que
era isso o futuro pela frente e se essa
a minha atividade profissional o fato é
que no final do estágio no consultório
que acompanhavam estágio nesse comer num
precinho era assim treinador professor
para qualquer atividade relacionada com
isso é que ele não estava a ver bem o
filme da minha vida estava aqui para
escrever um milhão de frente para ela no
entanto passado dois meses Recebi um
convite para lecionar
o tempo passou o meu para ser parceiro
com ele e lecionar em uma escola
se você tem passavam os tempos voltei a
receber um outro convite heim já não
existe resolvi arriscar e se dispor a
apresentar a 30 anos que sou professor e
a 30 anos tem que fazer diferente com a
luz da frente os alunos diferentes que
conhecer perder no primeiro ano
impressionar não sei por lecionar é o
curso geral no outro recurso
complementar o outono onde como fazer
exame Alfa 1 ano com matéria de dois ou
três anos é preciso arranjar estratégias
diferentes para alunos diferentes para
promover o seu sucesso em planta alunos
para atingirem as competências e os
conhecimentos que eram necessários o
fato é que passam pela minha imaginação
pela minha criatividade um fez com um
tivesse que gerava mónicas pelos
aprender
o delas químicas e físicas matemática e
introdução à informática e portanto era
preciso arranjar estratégias na altura
não havia formulários nas provas assim
mesmo de saber as coisas assim não
consegui memórias resolvi ir em um
conseguir em trabalha durante um dia
inteiro quando chega o fim do dia já
está cansado e é muito difícil ter
Hospital multifuncional para uns tem os
seus estudos por isso é preciso fazer
estratégias diferentes para fazer uns
assim o sucesso dos alunos
e agora bem
E se nós não quanto professores Rio há
30 anos colección não expulsaram os para
mudar e bem vestidos mudança as coisas à
nossa volta não vão um nossos
terminarmos não vemos o sucesso dos
alunos
e vamos sair 1989 era tudo muito
diferente
o fato é que os alunos na altura nos
intervalos faziam coisas diferentes de
agora jogavam futebol jogado ou Berlim e
agora os meus alunos tem a ver com isso
temos que viver em São essas as novas
solicitações importante foi com base
nisso em para fazer diferente com os
alunos diferentes de agora em na escola
onde leciona na escola secundária da
Portela uma escola bons alunos em que a
vez por cento de alunos com dificuldades
temos que olhar também pra esses foi a
pensar nesses alunos que foi criado o
projeto ajuda que mais tarde passou a
ser um projeto essa 3D
o objetivo era trabalhar com alunos com
dificuldades usadas Project bem também
a rota para ir de carona ideia era fazer
projetos com recursos robôs programados
e fazer ruim integração todas as
disciplinas no projeto apenas essas em
um mês de português a história a
geografia A qualquer Travessa Rafa
bom descanso então a questão 22 alunos
814 pensões idas muito com três que
tensões em seis com duas um dos com
dificuldades a quem o ensino regular não
sei nada foi com esses exames alguma
coisa diferente erosão Museu das
Comunicações e sermos recebidos nos
vemos por um assistente virtual da ideia
de fazer um dia do seu problema os
alunos a fazer muita coisa a fazer muita
preparação e nós professores também
devemos fazer adaptação a todas as
disciplinas começaram por pesquisar vida
e obra seis artistas plásticos
portugueses
o verão um usar quando e onde verão
a fazer um enquadramento histórico da
época em que eles fizeram tiveram de
fazer uma biografia para a disciplina de
português que colega com um fizeram uma
short uma biografia pequena foi
transmissível para inglesa para francês
paralelamente foram comendo as obras
queriam reconhecer em contexto de sala
de aula reproduziram obras dos artistas
que foram escolhidos ao presenças que
foram selecionadas pela colega estamos a
fazer um trabalho interdisciplinar um
trabalho de maneira diferente os alunos
estão aprender sem obrigação de aprender
isso que interessa estes alunos voltarem
apanhar um rosto em um ensino o gosto
pela aprendizagem um estado que está na
escola e sentir-se alguém facto este
assunto
e foram um mas Preste bastante depois a
produzirem as obras um contexto de sala
de aula uma altura fazer para o tempo do
Brasil que foi trabalhar com a colega
uma inspeção visual e mesmo relacionava
programação e vai preparação não tinha a
vertente da programação estão os alunos
foram preparados burro em paralelo
a concluírem a fase de investigação a
fase de produção das obras de produção
em sala de aula pois correndo
paralelamente a fase
a aprendizagem a trabalhar com os alunos
aprenderam a montar robôs haverá
estrutura a programar o bebé a fazer
alterações adaptações testes este
processo não depende esse mundo nenhum
não ser um aluno mais fraco que cada um
oferece uma grande discrepância entre os
cada um conseguindo atingir o objetivo
Afinal independentemente se a mais
depressa ou mais devagar motinha sempre
para vemos na frente já aprenderam
diferente de maneira diferente O
importante era um aprendência
desenvolver-se em competências 15 1
sucesso no trabalho
é o mesmo tempo
E aí
a festa acontecia uma atividade prática
simulada acordar vamos estar com a
fazendo atividades por todo o país e os
nossos alunos passaram uns a professores
temos muitos jogos em escolas Porque
estão presentes foram dinamizadas pelos
nossos alunos um alvo eram os colegas de
outras escolas são a opção sem função
montaram rosto e programaram para
resolver pequenos desafios também uma
parte social do projeto até para fazer
uma ligação à comunidade os nossos
alunos tiveram a oportunidade de
semanalmente passar duas horas no
serviço de Pediatria dos hospitais de
Lisboa Na altura foi o Hospital de Santa
Maria neste momento já vamos também a
fazer
o hospital Dona Estefânia estão tem
ideia é analisar as atividades de
programação e robótica com os meninos
que estão doentes ao mesmo tempo que os
meninos têm uma tarde referente os
nossos alunos podem por em prática o que
aprenderam os sentidos no texto não se
pode trazer a conversão extra para sua
aprendizagem
e também usamos um projeto ou sugestão
da criação uma página nas redes sociais
vamos um projeto projeto
E ai não é nacional está no evento uma
ciência na escola a formação e eventos
concursos ao mesmo tempo em projetos
nossos foi aceita nos tiveram
oportunidade de explicar esse projeto ao
Jardim fez com quem tem uns sentem cada
vez mais um que vácuo
a 90 em participamos Mas neste caso foi
veio trazer uma chancela de qualidade ao
trabalho no espelho com ea111
em Portugal best lenses Engenharia
e esta vento conversa constante é um
concurso de projetos para alunos do
terceiro 5 e note-se que estes não
estavam a tentar concluir não não é mim
o projeto foi um respeitar certos para
os passou uns 22 finalistas um teve uma
menção honrosa
e criando a os melhores alunos das
escolas concorrentes os alunos do curso
profissional conseguir vai fazer um
trabalho excelente qualidade na sua
carne aprovados
de repente Fomos convidados para
apresentar o projeto Hand sign-on
Systems Portugal um
ao final do evento com os convidados um
projeto esteve a representar Portugal no
Science on station europeu lembro 22
alunos com a oito com quatro extensões 8
com três pensões seis com duas que
tensões fizeram um projeto premiado pela
ordem dos Engenheiros representam
Portugal não sai em São esteja europeu
o motor lá conclusões que partiram
desmotivados partiram sem vontade de
estar na escola até ao fim do ano efe
acabaram na sua envia por com ele não no
ano não é conseguir os seus status não
posso dizer que mais de setenta e cinco
porcento desses alunos conseguiram
concluir o ensino secundário pela Via
racional e funcional sem sacar repitido
mais um ano explicar a questão
que são as Com estes extremos no país
Quantos professores não têm estarão
dispostos a fazer em frente com alunos
na frente obrigado